التقطير الكمي بطريقة Krylov أو KQD اختصاراً يشير إلى حل مسألة قيمة مصفوفية
عن طريق إسقاط المصفوفة على فضاء جزئي يُحضَّر على حاسوب كمي بما يتوافق مع طريقة Krylov وهي
منهجية قوية من الجبر الخطي الكلاسيكي خلال هذا الفيديو سنستكشف لماذا طريقة Krylov مفيدة
وكيف ومتى نطبقها على الحواسيب الكمية
إذاً ما هي طريقة Krylov لنفترض أن لدينا مصفوفة H مرتبطة بمسعى علمي أو تجاري بها n صف و n
عمود نحن مهتمون بأدنى قيمة ذاتية e0 والمتجه الذاتي المقابل psi0 لنعرّف
متجهاً ابتدائياً v قد يكون مستوحى من بنية h أو قد يكون عشوائياً تماماً فضاء Krylov الجزئي
من الرتبة r الذي نكتبه Kr يُولَّد بتطبيق h على هذا
المتجه الابتدائي r ناقص واحد مرة مع إضافة نتيجة كل تطبيق متتالٍ لـ h
إلى مجموعة المتجهات المولِّدة أي أن Kr هو الفضاء المولَّد بالمتجهات v
و hv و h تربيع v وهكذا هذه المتجهات لن تكون عموماً متعامدة
كلاسيكياً نجري عادةً عملية تعامد تشبه كثيراً إجراء Gram-Schmidt تبدأ
بتوحيد المتجه الابتدائي v وتسمي الناتج v0 ثم للمتجه التالي Hv تطرح منه
إسقاطه على v0 لجعل المتجهين متعامدين ثم توحد الناتج تستمر هكذا
بتطبيق H مرة أخرى وجعل الناتج متعامداً مع جميع المتجهات المضافة سابقاً حتى تبني R
متجه متعامد وموحد مطلوب لتوليد فضاء Krylov الجزئي ذي البعد R
بمجرد حصولك على هذا الفضاء الجزئي تُسقط مصفوفتك عليه وتُقطِّر المصفوفة المُسقطة الأصغر هناك
تفاصيل دقيقة وتوسعات لكن هذه هي طريقة Krylov في أبسط مستوياتها
للحصول على فهم أفضل لكيفية عملها لنلقِ نظرة على مثال بسيط إذا كانت H هذه المصفوفة و V اختير ليكون هذا
المتجه فسنبدأ بتوحيد V لتوليد المتجه الثاني في فضاء Krylov الجزئي نطبق
H مرة واحدة على المتجه الابتدائي ثم نجعل الناتج متعامداً مع v0
القليل من الجبر يعطينا هذا لـ v1
هذا ليس مفيداً لمصفوفات بهذا الحجم الصغير ولن نتوقف عادةً عند بعد Krylov يساوي اثنين لكن إذا أردنا
إسقاط H على فضاء Krylov الجديد K2 سنفعل ذلك باستخدام مصفوفة V
التي تحتوي على متجه Krylov في كل عمود ومرافقها المنقول الذي يحتوي على متجهات Krylov في الصفوف عندها
نحصل على هذه المصفوفة
هذه المصفوفة تقنياً لها بعد أقل من الأصلية طبعاً هذا التخفيض ليس مفيداً بهذا
الحجم هذه الطريقة مصممة لتخفيض مصفوفات بآلاف أو حتى ملايين الصفوف والأعمدة
إلى حفنة صغيرة فلماذا طرق Krylov مفيدة اتضح أن هذه الوصفة البسيطة
لتطبيق المؤثر هي غالباً الطريقة الأكثر كفاءة للاقتراب من حالة القيمة الأدنى أو الحالة الأرضية لمصفوفة
مؤثر لنجعل هذا أوضح قليلاً مع ترك البرهان الكامل للنص المرافق نريد أن
نحل مسألة من الشكل H مطبقاً على المتجه x يعطينا ثابتاً ما مضروباً في المتجه x لنبدأ بتخمين
للمتجه الذاتي x0 هذا مجرد حل تقريبي له خطأ نسميه e0 الآن نريد أن
نحدّث هذا التخمين ونسميه x1 ونأمل أن يحسّن تقريبنا يمكننا التعبير عن هذا بأنه
x0 الأصلي مضافاً إليه تصحيح p0 لم يُحدد بعد يمكننا
تكرار هذه العملية بشكل تكراري مضيفين المزيد والمزيد من متجهات التصحيح pi
من الواضح أننا نريد تقليل الخطأ لكن ليست الحالة فقط ما يهمنا بل نهتم أيضاً بتأثير
h على تلك الحالة فالكمية التي نريد تقليلها حقاً هي معيار H لهذا الخطأ أو معيار
تأثير h على هذا الخطأ
الآن نرى أن هذا تعبير يتضمن p0 ويمكننا أن نسأل أنفسنا ما خيارات p التي تقلل
معيار H للخطأ بأكبر كفاءة من أي فضاء يجب أن نختار التصحيح في ظروف
معينة مثل عندما تكون h متماثلة وموجبة التحديد اختيار التصحيحات R الأولى من داخل Kr يتبين
أنه الأمثل بعبارة أبسط نحتاج طريقة ما لتحضير فضاء جزئي جيد نستطيع
إسقاط الهاملتوني عليه وفي كثير من الحالات فضاء Krylov الجزئي هو الفضاء المولَّد بمتجهات
التصحيحات الأكثر كفاءة لتخميننا الابتدائي
للبرهان الحقيقي انظروا النص المرافق لهذا الفيديو
كل ما وصفناه حتى الآن يمكن تنفيذه كلاسيكياً إذاً كيف ومتى نستخدم حاسوباً كمياً
للمصفوفات الكبيرة جداً يمكن أن تتطلب طريقة Krylov أوقات حوسبة طويلة وكميات كبيرة من الذاكرة الوقت
المطلوب لعملية المصفوفة H على v يتناسب مع N تربيع في أسوأ الحالات
وهذا يُفعل لكل متجه نريده في فضائنا الجزئي بعد الفضاء الجزئي R عادةً ليس جزءاً كبيراً
من N وغالباً يتناسب مع لوغاريتم N فتوليد جميع المتجهات يتناسب
مع رتبة N تربيع لوغاريتم N
رغم وجود خطوات أخرى كالتعامد إلا أن هذا هو التناسب المهيمن الذي يجب تذكره
الحوسبة الكمية تتيح لنا تغيير الخصائص التي تحدد تناسب الوقت والموارد
المطلوبة بدلاً من الاعتماد على حجم المصفوفة n بشكل شامل سنرى أشياء مثل عدد التصويبات
وعدد حدود Pauli غير المتبادلة التي تشكل الهاملتوني
لنستكشف كيف يعمل هذا
تذكروا أن المؤثر الذي يُطوّر حالة كمية زمنياً هو الأُسّي لـ iH على h بار ومن
الشائع جداً خاصةً في الحوسبة الكمية إسقاط h بار من الترميز
إحدى طرق فهم وحتى تحقيق دالة أسية كهذه لمؤثر هي النظر في توسيع
سلسلة Fourier لاحظوا أن هذه العملية المطبقة على متجه ابتدائي V تعطي مجموع حدود
بقوى متزايدة من H مطبقة على الحالة الابتدائية يبدو أننا نستطيع ببساطة بناء فضاء Krylov الجزئي عن طريق التطور
الزمني لحالة التخمين الابتدائية وهذا صحيح تقريباً التحفظ يكمن في
تحقيق التطور الزمني على حاسوب كمي حقيقي كثير من الحدود في الهاملتوني لن تتبادل مع
بعضها البعض فبينما بعض المؤثرات الأسية البسيطة مثل e أس سالب i z تقابل circuits
بسيطة الهاملتونيات العامة لا تقابل ذلك وبما أنها تحتوي على حدود غير متبادلة
لا يمكننا ببساطة تفكيك الأسية إلى جداء أسيات بسيطة كما نفعل مع الأعداد
هذا ليس تافهاً لكنه عملية مدروسة جيداً في الحوسبة الكمية ننفذ التطور الزمني
على الحواسيب الكمية باستخدام عملية تسمى Trotterization وهي بحد ذاتها موضوع غني لكن على مستوى عالٍ جداً
بتقسيم التطور الزمني إلى خطوات صغيرة لنقل M خطوة نحدّ من تأثيرات عدم تبادلية
الحدود لنسمِّ فضاء Krylov الجزئي من الرتبة r الذي ولّدناه في السياق الكلاسيكي باستخدام قوى h
مباشرةً فضاء Krylov القوي KPr
الآن نولّد فضاءً مشابهاً باستخدام مؤثر التطور الزمني الموحد u المعطى بالأسية لـ iHt
سنشير إلى هذا بفضاء Krylov الموحد KUr
فضاء Krylov القوي KPr الذي نستخدمه كلاسيكياً لا يمكن توليده مباشرةً على حاسوب كمي لأن H
ليس مؤثراً موحداً استخدام فضاء Krylov الموحد يمكن إثبات أنه يعطي ضمانات تقارب
مشابهة لفضاء Krylov القوي
تحديداً خطأ الحالة الأرضية يتقارب بكفاءة طالما أن الحالة الابتدائية V لها تداخل مع
الحالة الأرضية الحقيقية لا يتلاشى أسياً وطالما توجد فجوة كافية بين القيم
الذاتية هنا قوى u تصبح خطوات زمنية مختلفة القوة k من u هي التقدم
بزمن قدره k ضرب dt
يمكننا تسمية عنصر الفضاء الجزئي المُطوَّر زمنياً لمدة إجمالية kdt بـ sk يمكننا إسقاط
الهاملتوني H على فضاء Krylov الموحد KUr بمعنى آخر
نحسب كل عنصر مصفوفي لـ H في أساس KUr سنشير إلى هذه
المصفوفة المُسقطة بـ H tilde عناصر المصفوفة لـ H tilde معطاة بقيم التوقع هذه التي يمكن
تقديرها باستخدام الحاسوب الكمي
تذكروا أن H يمكن كتابتها كمجموع مؤثرات Pauli على qubit مختلفة وأنه ليس كل مؤثرات Pauli
يمكن قياسها في آنٍ واحد يمكننا ترتيب حدود Pauli في مجموعات من حدود متبادلة وقياسها كلها
معاً لكن قد نحتاج مجموعات كثيرة لتغطية جميع الحدود لذا عدد مجموعات التبادل المميزة التي يمكن
تقسيم الحدود إليها NGCP يصبح مهماً إذا استخدمنا فضاء Krylov موحد ببعد r فإن
المصفوفة الناتجة سيكون أبعادها r ضرب r إذا كان r أقل بكثير من n فقد حققنا
تقدماً مفيداً وعادةً r أقل بكثير من 100 مما يعني أننا نستطيع تقطيرها بسهولة على حاسوب
كلاسيكي لكن تذكروا أن sn و sm لن يكونا عموماً متعامدين من
الممكن أحياناً تقطير مصفوفة في أساس غير متعامد لكن هناك أسباب عددية وفيزيائية
للتحويل أولاً إلى أساس متعامد لذا نحل مسألة قيمة ذاتية معممة باستخدام مصفوفة Gram وهي S
العنصر mn من مصفوفة Gram معطى بالجداء الداخلي لـ sm و sn
كل من عناصر H tilde و S تُحسب باستخدام اختبار Hadamard
مسألة القيمة الذاتية المعممة تصبح عندها هكذا
كما ذكرنا أعلاه بعد فضاء Krylov الموحد R أصغر أسياً من بعد المصفوفة
الابتدائي N لذا هذه المسألة بسيطة الحل كلاسيكياً
للتلخيص نبدأ بحالة مرجعية ثم نطورها لفترات زمنية مختلفة لتوليد فضاء Krylov
الموحد الجزئي نسقط الهاملتوني على هذا الفضاء الجزئي ونقدّر أيضاً تداخلات
متجهات الفضاء الجزئي أخيراً نحل مسألة القيمة الذاتية المعممة ذات البعد الأدنى كلاسيكياً لنقارن ما
يحدد التكاليف الحسابية لاستخدام تقنية Krylov كلاسيكياً وكمياً رسمنا هذا
بالفعل للنسخة الكلاسيكية ولا توجد مقابلات مثالية بين المنهجين الكلاسيكي والكمي لجميع الخطوات لكن هذا الجدول يجمع بعض
تناسبات الخطوات المختلفة للنظر فيها تذكروا أن الهاملتونيات عموماً لها حدود لا يمكن قياسها معاً لأنها
لا تتبادل نرتب حدود الهاملتوني في مجموعات من مؤثرات Pauli المتبادلة التي يمكن قياسها معاً وقد نحتاج
مجموعات كثيرة لتغطية جميع الحدود غير المتبادلة لبناء H tilde على حاسوب كمي نحتاج
قياسات منفصلة لكل مجموعة من سلاسل Pauli المتبادلة في الهاملتوني وكل منها يتطلب تصويبات كثيرة يجب فعل هذا لـ R
تربيع عنصر مصفوفي مختلف تقابل R تربيع مجموعة من عوامل تطور زمني مختلفة هناك
طرق أحياناً لتقليل هذا لكن في هذه المعالجة التقريبية الوقت المطلوب يتناسب تقريباً مع
عدد التصويبات ضرب عدد مجموعات حدود Pauli المتبادلة ضرب r تربيع
عناصر S يجب تقديرها وهذا يتناسب مع عدد التصويبات
ضرب r تكعيب نرى أن التقطير الكمي بطريقة Krylov قد يكون مفيداً في الحالات التي يكون فيها عدد مجموعات Pauli المتبادلة
في الهاملتوني صغيراً نسبياً
هذا الاعتماد في التناسب يقترح بعض التطبيقات حيث تكون طريقة Krylov مفيدة وأخرى حيث على الأرجح
لن تكون بعض الهاملتونيات لها تعقيد عالٍ عند ربطها بـ qubit تتضمن سلاسل Pauli كثيرة غير متبادلة
لا يمكن تقسيمها بسهولة إلى مجموعات متبادلة قليلة
هذا صحيح غالباً لمسائل الكيمياء الكمية مثلاً هذا التعقيد يقدم تحديين رئيسيين لـ
الحواسيب الكمية قريبة المدى أولاً تقدير كل عنصر من H tilde يصبح مكلفاً حسابياً بسبب
العدد الكبير من الحدود ثانياً circuits الـ Trotter المطلوبة تصبح عميقة بشكل مانع كلتا النقطتين
ستكونان أقل إشكالية عندما تصل الحواسيب الكمية إلى التسامح مع الأخطاء لكن يجب مراعاتهما على المدى القريب حتى الأنظمة ذات الربط الأبسط
من تلك الموجودة في الكيمياء الكمية قد تواجه نفس العوائق إذا كانت الهاملتونيات تحتوي على حدود غير متبادلة
كثيرة جداً طريقة Krylov أكثر فائدة حيث يمكن تقسيم الهاملتوني إلى مجموعات متبادلة قليلة نسبياً من مؤثرات Pauli
وحيث يسهل تنفيذ H في circuits الـ Trotter كلا الشرطين متحققان مثلاً
للعديد من نماذج الشبكات ذات الأهمية في الفيزياء KQD مفيد بشكل خاص إذا كان ما نعرفه عن الحالة
الأرضية قليلاً جداً وهذا ينبع من ضمانات التقارب المتأصلة فيه وقابليته للتطبيق في سيناريوهات حيث
الطرق البديلة غير ممكنة بسبب عدم كفاية المعرفة بالحالة الأرضية
بينما KQD أداة قوية فإن الجوانب المستهلكة للوقت في البروتوكول خاصةً تقدير كل
عنصر من الهاملتوني المُسقط وتداخل حالات Krylov تمثل فرصاً للتحسين
منهج بديل يتضمن تقريب حالة Krylov باستخدام circuits الـ Trotter ثم أخذ عينات من
الحالة المُقرّبة للحصول على إسقاط على الأساس الحسابي ثم إسقاط H على الفضاء الجزئي
المولَّد بحالات الأساس الحسابي هذه
في الحالات التي يكون فيها قابلاً للتطبيق هذا المنهج المعروف بالتقطير الكمي بطريقة Krylov القائم على أخذ العينات SKQD
يوفر محتملاً تخفيضات كبيرة في متطلبات الوقت والموارد مقارنةً بـ KQD التقليدي
دمج تقنيات فضاء Krylov الجزئي مع طرق أخذ العينات في SKQD يمثل حدوداً مثيرة في
الخوارزميات الكمية